vous le savez je sors beaucoup sont
loana d'or ça je suis un féru d'internet
croll un le scroll le scroll exactement
jusqu'où iront les maintenant au monde
hier c'est à dire je troll et nager trop
je suis tombé sur le classement des
personnalités
voilà les qui sont le plus recherché sur
le web à des personnalités télé sa
mesure la pop la popularité qualité des
personnalités télé alors j'ai le top 10
est ce que vous aviez ce que vous pouvez
me donner le top 10 qui à votre avis est
dans le top 10 justin bieber alors télé
en france qui avait animé motus aller
tout de suite la boule noire n'a pas été
c'est les gens qui ont été le plus
recherché
non on en voit qu'on embrassait jim
l'évidence c'est vous ah oui je suis
combien suit en deuxième position
[Applaudissements]
descendu de recherche ni corse ensuite
si nikos aliagas non na li na guînes
très bonnes réponses
il est 4e nagui avec 188 1180 de
recherche
attention c'est parti on y va gemmerlé
nous avec ollanta clos de koh lanta non
mais on embrasse fort que denis
brogniart
denis brogniart non combal non il ya des
femmes dont le oui on a aimé smith est
non rachid arhab et le mcs son nom ah
lalala lalala x lapix oui elle est 8ème
anne sophie lapix en train de s'élever à
80 où il était allé je vais vous en
donner
jean pierre pernaut numéro un jean
pierre pernaut je vais vous donner le
tiercé qaîda qui dans le tiercé c'est
une femme non lemoine
non karine le marchand non à geelong
zabeth une femme quand même oui mais je
pense alors par les chats vont briguer
une femme oui mais les meilleurs non
merci boccolini boccolini oui mais elle
n'est pas troisième allait neuvième long
référé karine ferri a les dents
classement les septièmes karine ferri
jean-marie nonce farine ont failli
honnête il ya aussi un autre journaliste
en a bien qui est sûr c'est nous les
scènes clés rares ou non à cannes trois
pros nous bouddha non car chazal non
mais je m'en sers longtemps fallait les
chéris je vous le donne et parce que
vous êtes en dixième position avec jean
marc morandini on embrasse bonne jean
marc et 10e en sixième position
michel drucker note michel damour et le
top 5 5e
alessandra sublet quatrième nagui
troisième sophie davant projet populaire
sophie davant et ensuite
très heureux d'être numéro 2 gr est
vraiment et en plus ce numéro un c'est
jean pierre pernaut ça va franchement on
a trouvé on a sauvé le match c'est bon
je me suis amusé à chercher derrière ce
qui apparaît ici avec votre nom derrière
en premier c'est très drôle
cédant par exemple isabelle morini bosc
qui arrive en premier regardez vous
savez mes isabelle morini bosc sur
google ce qui arrive en premier c'est et
en vélo ch 1 jure que c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez c'est moi quant aux dates
mémorables
regardez ce qui arrive les 3 pour les
trois premiers trucs regardez regardez
rémois bouchekif origines juives
freinera décès du frère était chef jean
michel mr débat regardez monsieur le
maire
[Applaudissements]
à
cette nouvelle action pour chaque élu
mais nommé à l'académie novelli vient
marquer alors qu'elle y met novelli
kelly b novelli copains portugal neymar
on dira pyramide énigmatique à 6 fois
les mâles au portugal à on allait
pouvoir les créations et neymar parce
que je crois qu'il ya eu oui en liant
son discours je ne sais pas qui a fait
lundi qui a fait la roche jean pascal
lacoste alors regarder et ça me fait
plaisir le reste puisque tpm père ils
vont bouger
sonnex a exactement
elle m'a parlé partie de tété beau
dossier tient géraldine maillet regard
des mannequins verra type o negative wa
daniel s'attaquent souvent à vera
tifaoui c'est vrai bâton votre compagnon
exactement il a bradé l'avenir des six
mais ne put on a des images
gmac a dû regarder madiama castaldi
bodyboard
[Applaudissements]
gilbert des bombes à mon avis gilles
verdez qu'ils se cachent ils verdès
micropénis la lourdeur bat gilles verdez
à fatoumata et valérie bénaïm tiens y'a
quoi venus regarder
valerie vili ce très étonnant jeunes
nombreux chiens enfin way est ce cas là
aussi des images wii wheel et et moi
alors où est la conscience mais j'ai
regardé mois ce qui a regardé ce cas
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
sourire c'est horrible c'est horrible ce
sont les choses les plus recherchés
quand on tape beau non